انتكاسة أخرى
لقوات الجيش الأوكراني لفلاديمير بوتين تقول إنها دمرت
هذا العمود من المركبات الروسية ولكن
صدق أو لا تصدق أن الجيش الأوكراني قد يستخدم البعض منها ،
فهذه الوحدة من الدفاع الإقليمي لأوكرانيا تعمل على
إصلاح ميكانيكا المعدات العسكرية الروسية التي تم الاستيلاء عليها
تعمل يومًا بعد يوم في
كثير من الأحيان  باستخدام أجزاء الخردة
لإعادة المركبات المدرعة إلى ساحة المعركة ، انظر إلى
كل الأشياء التي لديهم هنا ،
ولديهم كابلات معدنية قديمة ، يخبرنا الرجال هنا
أنهم يستخدمون كل ما في
وسعهم لجعل هذه المركبات مناسبة مرة أخرى
وتغلب على فلاديمير بوتين بمفرده
عندما زرنا المجموعة كانت تصلح
العديد من ناقلات الجند المدرعة
وشاحنة وقود ، لقد أظهروا لنا أيضًا
مقطع الفيديو هذا لصواريخ يزعمون أنهم
استولوا عليها والتي قالوا أيضًا إنها قد
تم إطلاقها بالفعل على الروس
بينما تم الاستيلاء على بعض المركبات
أثناء  المعركة والطواقم
الروسية قتلت أو أسرت في كثير من الأحيان
الجنود الروس ببساطة تركوا معداتهم
وهربوا يوري جي  أخبرني أووليدوف ، نائب
قائد هذه الوحدة ،
أن الجنود الروس خائفون
ومحبطون ، يقول إنهم يخشون
أن ينفصلوا عن بعضهم البعض
لأنهم يطلقون النار عليهم من كل الأدغال
التي نسميها.
من خلال الغابات ،
تقوم وحدة الدفاع الإقليمي أيضًا بتدريب
مقاتلين جدد للمساعدة في الدفاع عن
عاصمة أوكرانيا ويظهرون لنا بعض الأسلحة
التي تلقوها من الولايات المتحدة والدول الحليفة
مثل
سلاح Panzerfaust III الألماني الصنع المضاد للدبابات ، هل
هو فعال سألت  قال نائب
القائد إنه فعال للغاية في إطلاق النار على الدبابات ،
حيث قال
إن القوات الأوكرانية تواصل صد
التقدم الروسي في كييف وأماكن أخرى ،
لكن خسائرهم كبيرة
وكذلك قتل الأفراد العسكريين
والمدنيين بنيران روسية ،
قال الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي لـ CNN
's fareed zakaria في
مقابلة حصرية نفقد الناس
على أساس يومي الأبرياء على
الأرض الروسية ل  لقد جاءنا لإبادتنا
لقتلنا ويمكننا أن نثبت أن
كرامة شعبنا وجيشنا
أننا قادرون على التعامل مع مسرحية قوية يمكننا
الرد
عليها بالرد بأي أسلحة
يمكنهم الحصول عليها بأيديهم  حول ما إذا كان
هؤلاء المقاتلون يأتون من حلفاء في الخارج أو من عدوهم ، فإن هؤلاء المقاتلين يقولون إن أي شيء
يقود ويطلق النار سيتم استخدامه
ضد القوة الغازية لفلاديمير بوتين.